i think the big problem that's staring
everyone in the face
in america right now that we're either
going to fall apart or find a way to
work through
is that and i think on some level
everybody knows this that
this whole thing doesn't work anymore
and from my perspective now
i'll admit this is my bias i'm a
libertarian but from my perspective
the big central problem here is that the
government got
way too powerful and way too big and
when you have
this much power rooted in washington dc
now the fact that we have drastically
different cultures in the country which
has always been true
brooklyn and alabama have never been the
same thing you know what i mean but now
it's this huge center of power that
really was tremendously built up in the
bush and obama and trump years
and now one side gets control of it and
rules over the other side or the other
side gets control and rules over the
other side so now you have to fight
a civil war over who gets control of
this every five years yes and at a
certain point
americans are going to have to say do we
really want to do this anymore
because the only alternative to this is
some form of decentralization
so it could be as drastic as secession
where we just go hey we don't need to
all be one country i mean we hate each
other's guts
why are we a country what are we
benefiting from from being in a country
with
like one side looks at the other side as
baby murderers and the other side looks
at the other side as nazis it's like
okay so why are we together would you
ever be in a friendship with someone who
you thought that about
or the other answer it's short of
secession is just decentralization
to scale back the power of the central
federal government
allow state and local governments to
have more authority
let peop understand we all have to
accept that in portland
they're not going to live the same way
that they do in florida and
a lot you know lots of other examples
and that's why it won't work
because california is inviting of
non-citizens into the country
and there are porous borders between
california and the surrounding states
and that means that if you live in say
nebraska you have a very real
uh threat to your laws if there are
people who can enter easily so let's say
nebraska says we don't allow you know
illegal immigration
they can enter in easily through
california there's no security and they
can easily pass from there into another
state and then come to nebraska
so then what do we get do we get state
borders where are they checkpoints well
no it all depends on the employment laws
some countries benefit from literally
what i would say is akin to human
slavery and allow immigrants to come in
and work for pennies on the dollar
other states don't allow it and say hey
if you don't if you're not a citizen you
can't really work here
and they don't incentivize this kind of
corporate slavery of of the immigrant
class
that essentially in my opinion exploits
them and creates a lose-lose situation
for everyone
well all you have to do honestly is not
make it illegal to discriminate
so you just have to get rid of laws that
like you don't need these force
association laws and you can basically
just say that like look people have a
right to discriminate
and not let certain people into their
communities hire them at their
businesses not and now
under current situations you'll have big
fat lawsuits but you'd have to get rid
of that stuff
but the pitch to california would have
to be something like look
you guys can have everything you want if
you're your own state
i mean you got the votes for all of it
now the problem they're going to have is
it's all going to fall apart and none of
it's going to work which they've already
experienced with like their
their train system and the medicare for
all proposals and everything like it
just doesn't work
but you're going to the only way i
understand what you're saying it's just
not going to work and and you're right
there's there's a lot of reasons to
think it's not going to work
but this isn't going to work either what
we're currently doing and so you have to
almost go like
well look the pitch has to be
how much more of this can we keep doing
because by the way look
trump the next trump might be 10 times
worse than donald trump
he might actually be what the left
thought donald trump was you know like
the republicans aren't going the
likelihood that a republican as we know
today wins
in four years i think is slim what will
end up happening is the republican in
four years will be kind of like a
center-left
individual by today's standards so well
i should say
by a true center-left individual and
it's because
if someone like trump let's say we got
somebody who had very very similar
policies
but was not uh you know abrasive and was
very charismatic
the media would annihilate them they
would say it's a smooth talking
lie just another nazi look his policy is
the same as trump
it would never work so what's
consistently happened is that the right
has been being is being pulled left
every step of the way because they're
desperate to appease the media
well that's not the right as much as it
is the republican establishment but
that's very true for the republican
establishment
and this is why they're they're smoked
it's not because of trump
that trump didn't destroy the
republicans trump brought a whole bunch
of new people into the republican party
trump just got them more votes than
they've ever gotten
on a presidential ticket so it's not
it's not that trump destroyed the party
the problem is that the republican party
deserves to be they they have
nothing to stand on right like what can
the republic what
does mitch mcconnell stand well right if
you if you take trump out of the picture
what what is the republican party can
they say that they what have they
conserved
have they have they protected the
constitution do they have do they have
claim to the bill of rights
do they have claim to limited reducing
the deficit right
do they have any claim to small
government do they have any claim to
tradition of any sense cultural
tradition they stand for what the left
stood for 10 years ago
that's all they ever stand for there's
none of them would have the courage
to oppose gay marriage by the way i'm
not i'm for gay marriage i'm not saying
they should i'm just saying
they don't have a claim to anything look
at look at
mccain and you know mitt romney and we
go back all those years and where their
stances were on cultural issues
and now look what the republican party
is today for i think there's good things
because i agree
like i'm for gay marriage and i'm for
you know freedoms and civil liberties
and things like that
i actually lean left a lot on on social
issues too
i just think the woke left is
particularly authoritarian about it but
one of the things jack murphy brings up
is that it was the republican party
accepting gay marriage that allowed him
to actually vote republican
and support donald trump in four years
oh there will be a republican i'm sure
and they will be substantially more
progressive and more woke
than anyone today in fact they probably
will be to a certain degree woke
they'll probably be kind of like me
where it's like they used to be a
liberal
they're kind of left on some issues but
they're called far right
yeah and they'll still get attacked and
destroyed in the media i don't see how
they'll actually win
even if they do move left well the left
made a very important strategic move by
aligning themselves with big tech and
saying you guys could do whatever you
want
but you got to work with us and they do
work in tandem in such a way
that's it's even entangled with the cia
but again you made a very good point
the republicans are pretty much
democrats 10 years ago and the bigger
point you made is the common sense
solution to all of this if you have the
big
government just decentralize it let
people live
how they want to live individually
because when you have a government that
has enough money to give to other
countries
that means they're taking too much money
away from their taxpayers they're too
powerful
and and they should be scaled to size
where people
get to have their individual expression
of liberty
their individual expression of culture
do what you want to do if you're
california if
you're in new york city but if you're
alabama let alabama do
whatever they want to do alabama here's
the problem the people who live
in give me a red state texas right a
large portion
don't want abortion to be legal right
issues like that
they say abortion is murder it is
violence and they won't allow that in
their country so they will continue to
fight at the federal level
for supreme court justices to overturn
what they view as
abhorrent and what should be illegal
activity the left will say
we can't allow them the controls of
federal government over everybody listen
but the federal government could just
say it's a state issue no they can't
because the left will say
the right will say we are not going to
allow new york to murder babies
yeah but you know what i don't think
you're right about that because the
right has been
losing for so long that just
allowing texas to ban abortion would be
such a huge win for them
there's already it's like yeah guys
either way they can murder babies in new
york
okay but at least now under this system
they're not going to be murdering them
in your area now and you know what i
think that would actually please a lot
of right-wing people in texas
and yeah it would piss off left-wing
people in new york they would still go
for the reigns of federal power to tell
texas what to do
yes probably because that's in the
because the federal government
incentivizes
mindset if the federal government
doesn't incentivize it and doesn't say
we're going to rule for everyone
then it's a state by state issue and
individuals could say i want to live in
new york city where i have these
freedoms or i want to live in texas
where i have these different freedoms
but we should focus on
protecting freedom but rather than
limiting listen i completely agree with
you but i also think that this is
getting to a point
where this is less like an ideological
preference or a suggestion
and this is more like a doctor telling
you you need a blood transfusion yes now
you might say like well i don't know how
we're gonna get this blood transfusion
it might be hard to do it's like okay
well you're gonna die
like this is not a joke this country is
on a suicide mission right now
and everybody knows that this isn't a
game anymore it's i remember back in the
in the ron paul days right ron paul used
to always basically say that i mean
those weren't his words but he would
basically say
this country's on a suicide mission like
this is an unsustainable path it wasn't
just like
look i'm a libertarian and i have this
ideology and i think we should all live
this way
he was telling you that this system is
doomed to fail
and back then even when he convinced me
of it it was still kind of an
abstraction it was a concept
now we're seeing it we're watching it
this country is on a suicide mission
and this is the only solution to it so
we have to
try somehow to move in that direction
because the truth is
what you were saying about a right wing
or a republican winning
you're right and you make good points
but the we are going to go in a populist
direction one way or the other for the
simple reason
that this type of corruption that just
screws over the average person so much
always leads to populism
yeah you can't that what we just had
this last year was the biggest transfer
of wealth from the middle class to the
upper
upper class in human history i mean it's
just been an attack on small businesses
and massive bailouts for big
corporations big banks
um they're all doing the integration of
our currencies well and that and that
goes right along with the same trend i
mean when the new money gets created it
always goes to the top first and they
get all of the wealth
they extract wealth from the poor in the
middle class and when you have that
scenario
of course someone like bernie sanders or
someone like trump who speaks to the
average guy that hey let's take this
whole thing on and win for
you even if they both have some idiotic
ideas of how to do that
um that's always going to be popular and
then what that requires is more
government suppression in order to
suppress the populist voices
so we're going to be in this cycle
that's going to kill us in unless we
decentralize well they milked this
country to the tune of 28
trillion there's no going back from that
the larger economic ramifications are
terrifying the way i view what's been
happening is
we're two sides continually trying to
build a tower
to see in the other direction right let
me mention it this way you've got two
buildings
and the people on top are like i want to
see the other side i want to see the
mountains well i want to see the ocean
so the left builds a little higher and
now they can see the ocean so the rice
says well now i can't see so they keep
going up
eventually the towers are getting so big
they're starting to sway back and forth
and the bigger they get the more they
sway the more violent it becomes and
eventually they both snap
and collapse and crush under their own
weight that's what's happening if this
escalation keeps occurring until someone
finally
says i'm going to stop but you know what
people aren't going to stop you know why
i believe in freedom free expression
individual liberties individual rights
the constitution i don't like
authoritarianism be it from corporations
or the government
and there are people on the left who
think the government should
mandate what people do because the
planet is doomed they think we're on a
collision course that
with the planet the planet's gonna
explode and so they're willing to
destroy your life and sacrifice you for
the greater good it's a very utilitarian
versus deontological argument
you have people on the left saying the
needs of the many outweigh the needs of
the few
and then you have many people on the
right saying any act against an
individual is an amoral act that cannot
be
you know uh conducted so ultimately what
that leads to is one side saying i will
not let you destroy this planet
and the other side saying i will not let
you oppress individual rights
no one is going to back down from that
fight would you say you know what
in the interest of peace i will allow
the left to continue their expansion of
authority
and wokeness and and then all that
they're doing it now
i mean so you wouldn't what's the actual
but what's the actual proposal there
so in the interest of peace would i say
that
portland can go as woke as they want to
as long as they don't know what's that
on the rest of the country
no that they take the rest of the
country over and instill their ideology
over everyone else
no fighting no that that i think needs
to be fought against i mean because they
said
same thing they yeah you see the point
yeah why why would i
say to the woke authoritarian communist
types
that i'm going to let them oppress
people i won't
i'll say look in portland i've actually
where i was earlier the year in the year
was like shut it down that's crazy and
now i'm kind of like
it's portland they voted for it they
must want it who am i to intervene
but to in to to put that in the rest of
the country to see the woke left call
for the things they're calling for
when they're like it's it's the most
it's the craziest thing when i hear them
say
all we want to do is give the right
wingers health care but they're so dumb
they don't understand it it's like no
maybe you don't understand
they don't want to live by your rules
yeah look i'm with you okay and it's
it's kind of like it's the challenge is
daunting
you know what i mean and it's like but
it's worth attempting and to me
what you mean like a peaceful yes right
the only option that we have
is to as we were talking about before
that a military confrontation with the
most militarized government ever is not
going to work and it will just lead to
bloodshed all we have is the power of
ideas
and the truth is that there is
still a remnant of decency in the human
spirit
and a lot of people are there is a huge
movement of people
who are turned off by by the woke stuff
there's a huge movement of people who
are turned off
by a lot of the just swampiness of the
establishment in general the problem is
that
the other side always scares them back
into their base
right so a lot of the kind of like
liberal left who
doesn't like the woke stuff and there's
a lot of them out there i think the vast
majority of them are silent because
they're kind of cowards about it
um which i think is part of the
personality type of the liberal left in
general
but that so they're too cowardice to
ever be called racist
but then they see trump and they're like
okay well i this guy's too gross for me
so i'm just going to stick in this kind
of camp here
or some of them yeah well that's true
i'm going to vote
that is true too but the truth is that
you have to find different ways to
attack this stuff
and and what doesn't get confronted
enough to me
about the the whole woke movement is
that like
like people battle it and how stupid it
is and and that's kind of easy
and and it's true and it's just it's
divisive and it's racist and it's
horrible and it's also just really
really dumb
like it's really really dumb you can
this is why ben shapiro got so popular
because he'd
battle their woke ideas and and people
would just look at him be like this is
so like
absurdly ridiculous he can just shred
these ideas up
but what's not mentioned enough is what
is actually going on here
and how brilliant the whole woke
movement was
it's like why do you think this stuff is
pushed
by government and big corporations and
big banks at the highest level
like why is it it's like well what was
the left doing
ten years ago you know say whatever you
will about the left
ten years ago the left was standing
outside the big banks
screaming we are the 99 percent
you think that got some attention out of
people do you think it's crazy that all
of a sudden
they have completely thrown you off the
scent now
and just have you focusing on micro
aggressions just imagine
like i i was saying this uh to when i
was on a rogan a couple weeks ago to him
where i was like imagine your
uh goldman sachs exec right and you have
bernie sanders coming up and he's going
there should be no billionaires
and you're like huh and then some other
like woke kid comes up and goes i want
to talk about microaggressions
i think you'd be like yeah i have a
microaggressions guy has something he
wants to say let's let's focus on that
guy that scene
so this has all been just to pull the
wall over the
the eyes of the left because the left
when it's at its best
is actually a threat to this power
structure yeah
i want to show you guys this comic
because uh it's great
and i've mentioned it before it's a man
sitting at a desk
outside his window it's a business guy
sitting at his food desk with his things
you know his degrees on the wall and
outside is a bunch of people protesting
holding a big sign occupy wall street
stop corporate greed fat cats
and the man inside is smirking on the
phone and he says introduce them to
identity politics
and i remember because i was at occupy
wall street as was luke when this
started happening
when it went from we are the 99 percent
the big bangs have extracted the wealth
of the people for too long
to all of a sudden twinkle fingers
progressive stack if you're white you're
not allowed to speak
yeah well and when we look at all of
their kind of woke ideology it's meant
to divide and conquer whether it's your
family members whether it's your race
whether it's your sex whether it's your
identity
whatever little category they could put
you in to make you feel
different and make you fight someone
else who is not on your side
intersectional identifying as it or this
or whatever you want to do
you're creating essentially packs that
are meant to
drive wedges into our modern day culture
so we're at each other's throats
and being afraid to talk to each other
because you don't want to offend someone
if you use the proper pronouns or
what kind of civilization in society are
we living in where we can't even say hey
you buddy bloke whatever there's a guy
in the uk who went to jail for calling
someone a bloke
and this is why this is why the left
eats itself
it is not a bug it is a feature of what
they do
they don't want them to ever actually be
able to unify around anything cohesive
so everything they do is offensive my my
favorite moment
in this whole nonsense was when one
organization came out
it was like international organization
for women or something some i forgot
what's called who the name was
and they said whimxen w-o-m-x-n
why mixin that's i don't know and they
say it's pronounced women's
and they got attacked by the left and
they said
that using the word wmixon is offensive
because you are implying you need a
special word for trans women but trans
women are women
how dare you say this so then they
apologized and put it back to women and
they still got flack
because women is an old patriarchal term
that separates
the the the genders that don't exist and
the the point is
they've created an ideology that is
attacking itself on purpose
so that it can't unify against it we
used to we used to talk about
uh facts we used to talk about evidence
now we're talking about what are you
what's your identity
and i get attacked on this non-stop on
twitter you're a misogynist you're
i mean i'm like well you are right i
choose not to even engage in that
because i'm like
let's talk about the merits of this
debate and people don't
yes but it's it's it's look they've
turned
the best aspect of the left against
the left and made it a vice rather than
a virtue
in the same sense that look what they
did with the the terror wars
was they turned the right wing impulse
to be tough and protect your country and
defend the bill of rights this really
beautiful noble thing
and they turned that into slaughtering
poor people in third world countries
they take this noble thing and they make
it evil they're geniuses
and what they've done is they take this
leftist kind of impulse
to care about the marginalized which in
its purest form
is a good thing something that's a
society a moral society needs and
they've turned this into
attacking everyone for every stupid
reason but it's it's to luke's point
this is the perfect like it's the
perfect divide and conquer tactic
that can never you can make sure that
they never focus on the fact that
we have more in common with each other
than we ever will
with donald trump or joe when they're
fighting each other the corporations
do whatever they want and what i've said
before is that
when we had these civil rights groups
that were fighting against racism
fighting for
for social justice civil rights it was
kind of like
an immune immune response we had
something bad
and we said it's not we're not going to
succeed if we're divided all the time
and so this movement emerged for
equality under the law in the 1964 civil
rights act followed by loving v virginia
which said
under the law we are all americans and
we and that is our identity american
citizens
then we we start to get an immune
overreaction
now these people are looking for racism
everywhere they still are operating
under this risk like immune response but
it's more now like an autoimmune
disorder
attacking healthy cells thinking it's a
diseased cell
and that's when a living creature dies
there are numerous disorders that are
like that an overdirective
targeting the wrong thing and destroying
it okay so just really quickly it's a
very quick story but uh
my my buddy uh scott horton who i don't
know if you know him he's a genius he's
the managing editor at
antiwar.com he's the greatest anyway you
guys check out scott horton if you don't
know who he is
um but he was telling me this story and
there's a great example of like
how they they divide us with this stuff
when we should all be together
but it was at the bundy ranch standoff
and he was talking to one of these i
forget but it was one of the like
leaders in the black lives matter
movement at the time and he was
basically telling this lady he was like
you guys should stand with the bundy
ranchers
because you guys have so much in common
here and you could unify
and make it like a left and right thing
and really focus on who the enemy is
and uh she showed him a picture and it
was one of the
bundy ranchers had a f um blm
shirt on and he goes no c they hate us
they hate everything we stand for and he
goes no no no
that's bureau of land management
aka the cops yeah they hate the cops
right like they're the same as you it's
literally just a different
version of the same thing trying to
explain the bundy thing to people is
funny because it
comes up all the time i'm like yeah they
were they were criticizing blm and
they're like black lives matter and i'm
not a bureau of land management they're
like
oh like yeah in other words the federal
cops like it's
it's the same thing it's just literally
people who are
saying that they want to live their
lives and there are these federal
agents who are coming through and
bringing violence to them
for no justifiable reason and that is
something that
could unite people but you got to me the
way it to attack
the the woke stuff is more than just
calling it stupid and smashing it
because that's just been done to death
at this point
is to let good decent leftists know that
they have fooled you with this
and they have and they are laughing at
you those same bankers
are cracking up laughing that you're
talking about
white supremacy rather than talking
about
banker bailouts thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you